There's this door on the 10th floor of the Vox Media Office that I hate so much. God dammit. You're at this door wrong? Pretty regularly. Have you seen people misuse it? All the time, every day. Constantly. Me too, Kelsey.
Vox Media办公室10楼有一扇门，我讨厌透了。该死。你是不是经常在那扇门上吃瘪？挺经常的。你见过别人用错吗？一直都有，每天都在发生。没完没了。我也是，凯尔西。
But here's the thing. As soon as you start looking for confusing doors, they are everywhere. It's push. Why? I feel like Roman Mars would know about this. This is 99% invisible. And those doors you hate are called Norman Door. Um, what's a Norman Door?
但问题是，一旦你开始留意那些令人困惑的门，你会发现它们无处不在。那是推门。为什么？我觉得罗曼·马尔斯（Roman Mars）应该知道这件事。这是《99%隐形》（99% Invisible）。那些你讨厌的门被称为“诺曼门”（Norman Door）。嗯，什么是诺曼门？
Don Norman wrote the essential book about design. He is the Norman of the Norman Door. Alright and where is this guy? You must go to San Diego. Okay. Hi Joe. Hey, I'm Don Norman. I'm... She, you know, it's hard to describe what I am. Well, he's been a professor of psychology, professor of cognitive science,
唐·诺曼（Don Norman）写了一本关于设计的经典著作。他就是诺曼门里的那个“诺曼”。好的，那这位先生在哪儿？你得去圣地亚哥。好的。你好，乔。嘿，我是唐·诺曼。我是……怎么说呢，很难描述我的身份。嗯，他曾担任心理学教授、认知科学教授、
professor of computer science, a vice president of advanced technology at Apple. But for our purposes. I was spending a year in England. I got so frustrated with my inability to use the light switches and the water taps and the dollars even that I wrote this book. If I continually get a door wrong, is it my fault? No. In fact, if you continually get it wrong, it's a good way to have other people continually get it wrong. Good sign, that's a really bad door.
计算机科学教授，以及苹果公司先进技术副总裁。但就我们今天的主题而言。我在英国待了一年。我对自己在操作电灯开关、水龙头甚至门把手时的无能感到非常沮丧，于是我写了这本书。如果我总是用错一扇门，是我的错吗？不。事实上，如果人们总是用错，那说明这扇门本身就设计得很糟糕。
A Norman door is one where the design tells you to do the opposite of what you're actually supposed to do, or gives the wrong signal and needs a sign to correct it. Why does it need an instruction manual? That is why you have to have a sign that says push or pull. Why not make it obvious? It can be obvious, if it's designed right. There are a couple of really simple basic principles of design. One of them I will call discoverability. When I look at something I should be able to discover what operations I can do. The principle applies to a whole lot more than doors.
诺曼门是指那种设计引导你做出与预期相反的操作，或者给出了错误信号，需要贴个标签来纠正的门。为什么它需要说明书？这就是为什么你必须贴上“推”或“拉”的标签。为什么不让它一目了然呢？如果设计得当，它完全可以一目了然。设计有几个非常简单且基本的原则。其中之一我称之为“可发现性”。当我看到某样东西时，我应该能够发现我能对它进行什么操作。这个原则适用于远不止门的其他事物。
And it's amazing with many of our computer systems today. You look at it, there's no way of knowing what's possible. Should I tap it once or twice or even triple tap? So discoverability when it's not there, well you don't need to use something. Another is feedback. And somebody times there's no feedback. You have no idea what happened or why it happened. And these principles form the basis of how designers and engineers work today, commonly known as user or human-centered design. I decided at one point the word user was a bit degrading, why not call people people. And it's amazingly simple and amazingly seldom practice.
这在我们今天的许多计算机系统中非常神奇。你看着它，根本无法知道能做什么。我应该点一下、点两下还是点三下？所以，当缺乏可发现性时，你就没法使用它。另一个原则是反馈。有时根本没有反馈。你完全不知道发生了什么，或者为什么发生。这些原则构成了当今设计师和工程师工作的基础，通常被称为“用户中心设计”或“以人为本的设计”。我曾一度认为“用户”这个词有点贬义，为什么不直接称呼人为“人”呢？这非常简单，但实践起来却少之又少。
We call it inter-chip because it goes around in a circle. We go out and we observe what is happening today. We observe people doing the task. And from that we say, oh, we have some ideas. Here's what we should perhaps propose to do. Then you prototype your solution and test it. Quite often these are wrong at first. But each time we go around the circle,
我们称之为“循环”，因为它是一个不断往复的过程。我们走出去，观察当下正在发生的事情。我们观察人们执行任务的过程。由此我们得出结论：哦，我们有一些想法。这是我们或许应该尝试的方案。然后你制作原型并进行测试。通常这些方案起初都是错的。但每一次循环，
we do a better job of making the device. Until the point we're actually making something that really works. And this process has spread all over the world. And it turns out it's improving lives. From better everyday things like the ones that don't know about. To using the same process to solve huge problems in public health and developing countries. Water, sanitation, farming. Lots more.
我们都能把设备做得更好。直到我们最终制造出真正好用的东西。这个过程已经传播到世界各地。事实证明，它正在改善人们的生活。从像诺曼门这样的小事，到利用同样的过程解决公共卫生和发展中国家面临的巨大问题。水资源、卫生设施、农业等等。
So what'd be a better human-centered door? An ideal door is one that as I walk up to it and walk through it, center door. This kind of push bar with the piece sticking out on one side works well too. So you can see what side you're supposed to push on. The vertical bars could go either way. A simple little hand thing though sort of indicates pull. But we still have terrible, terrible doors in the world. So many have that. There are lots of things in life that are fairly standardized and therefore whether I buy
那么，什么是更好的以人为本的门呢？理想的门是当我走近并穿过它时，它能自然引导我。这种一侧突出的推杆也很好用。这样你就能看出该推哪一边。垂直把手可能让人困惑。但一个简单的手柄形状通常暗示着“拉”。然而，世界上仍然有许多糟糕透顶的门。很多门都是这样。生活中有很多东西是相当标准化的，因此我是否购买
this house or not is not a function of whether it has good doors in it. And so, except for safety reasons, doors tend not to be improved. But the tyranny of bad doors must end. I think that it's a really sh** design. Right, they put people in the middle, one in the push, and that should be a flat panel right here.
这栋房子，并不取决于它是否有好用的门。所以，除了安全原因外，门往往不会被改进。但糟糕门设计的暴政必须终结。我认为这设计真是烂透了。没错，他们把人放在中间，一边推，这里应该是一个平坦的面板才对。
And not a f***ing bullhand. That's how I feel about this far. It's very misleading. I agree. You're right, Becky. You're God damned right. And if we all thought like you, well, we might just design a better world together.
而不是一个该死的把手。我对这扇门就是这种感觉。它非常具有误导性。我同意。你说得对，贝基。你说得太对了。如果我们都像你这样思考，我们或许就能共同设计出一个更美好的世界。
It won't open because it's a security door. What a f*** are you doing? Hey, this is Joe from Vox. Thank you so much for watching. If you want to see more stuff like this, just come check us out at youtube.com slash Vox Vox. It was so much fun collaborating with 99% visible. As you can see, there's some improvements being made over here, but obviously not as improved as it could be. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
它打不开，因为这是安全门。你到底在干什么？嘿，我是Vox的乔。非常感谢观看。如果你想看更多类似的内容，请访问youtube.com/Vox。与《99%隐形》合作非常愉快。如你所见，这里做了一些改进，但显然还没达到最佳状态。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。